it's a real pleasure to be joined today
by Cass Sunstein who's a professor at
Harvard Law School and author of the new
book hashtag hashtag republic divided
democracy in the age of social media
it's so great to have you on and I'd
love to start just generally how did you
start the research and start the process
of thinking about the new book hashtag
Republic way in other words what was
going on in society that gave you this
idea well there were two different
tracks in terms of my own motivation the
concern was that Democrats are talking
to Democrats and Republicans to
Republicans and Republicans are saying
lock her up and Democrats are saying
that the Republican Party's gone insane
and the political polarization and
division seemed in some ways more acute
than at least has been observed in
recent times the intensity of it in
terms of doing the research well I did
what I guess academics are doomed to do
which is to read everything I could find
empirical on how people are using social
media and the Internet and also to do
some of my own research about how people
process information and update when they
learn new things when we think about you
know cognitive biases and and the
heuristics that folks like Daniel
Kahneman have written about we know that
the you know confirmation bias and sort
of a closed echo chamber and many of
these other mechanisms have been around
for a long time but in the book you
argue that as the Internet has become
more and more sophisticated and this
includes the the algorithms that
determine what you see on social media
websites and in search results etc that
it's making the problem particularly bad
right now is that right for many people
the opportunity to get stuff that is
completely outside your your little
information cocoon is fantastic so if
you want to learn things about products
or people or activities or perspectives
you can do that in a heartbeat and
that's great but it's also the case that
the same technologies that open up our
world
can fence it in so if you want to just
listen to stuff that is confirming your
own convictions or things that are
making you feel that boy you were even
right or that you thought or things that
will fence off topics that disturb you
or don't seem funds the technological
capacity to create a little de gated
community for yourself that is we
haven't seen anything like that in human
history and it seems as though some of
the mechanisms that are leading to this
could be for example the fact that
you're seeing what your friends on
Facebook post and and it's sort of
generally more likely that your Facebook
friends are more similar than different
in terms of political ideology but it
goes well beyond that doesn't it I mean
even when you look at search results on
search engines like Google where even if
you go in with a presumably open-minded
search something which could turn up
articles or adversarial information
maybe based on your point of view your
past search history may actually skew
the results you get even when trying to
get outside of your echo chamber that
seems like a much harder sort of nut to
crack in terms of the echo chamber
effect isn't it okay well let's start
with Facebook so Facebook has a newsfeed
which can be based in principle either
as you say on your friends or it could
be based on its own algorithm where
there would be some self sorting of you
into news that is consistent with let's
say your revealed predilections and it
looked like from the data as a little
while ago that both phenomena are
working that is that the algorithm has
some not huge but definite self sorting
so it'll shoot your stuff that fits with
what you like and also that people's own
clicking behavior in terms of their
interaction with their friends reflects
their pre-existing inclinations that's
not amazing but it's a bit disturbing
and if you put in both the Facebook
algorithm with people's own clicking
behavior then you can get
a well-defined tendency for let's say
Bernie Sanders supporters to be on
Facebook seeing a lot of Pro Bernie
Sanders ish stuff and let's say Donald
Trump supporters to be seeing exactly
the same and that's kind of the problem
that that I'm focused on in terms of
Google we actually have less information
about how different people search
histories affect what what comes up in a
search but as of a while back there was
some evidence that if you were a certain
type Google would know your search
history and feed you things that are
consistent with what it's learned that
you like now in some ways that's that's
good if you are really excited about
basketball if you put the word LeBron in
you're gonna get stuff about LeBron
James rather than and I confess I'm a
basketball plan so fan so I'm stumbling
over other LeBrons things but are some
if you're not a basketball fan if you're
interested in LeBron whatever which may
be as a person and some obscure country
or some historical figure or some
product that has nothing even LeBron
James you get that so there is some
evidence of that that's not so alarming
but if it is the case that your
political predilections are reflected in
your what google turns up then that's
like the Facebook phenomenon and it's
it's not so good for democracy is there
some way to or let me think the best way
to even sort of get into this topic I
mean I think that there's among many
there's the conventional wisdom that in
total the Internet has been a
democratizing force and I don't think
you know for most of our audience I need
to list the ways in which in which that
that could be argued what's your sense
sort of about that net effect when we
consider all of the ways in which the
Internet has created these echo chambers
and in some ways is furthering extremism
or sort of isolation of ideology etc can
we measure and is it relevant to measure
the sort of net democratization impact
of the internet more broadly well I'll
tell my reaction that it's very hard to
frame the question of net democratizing
impact with sufficient concreteness so
we can even test it empirically so you
can test the question are people
learning more about diverse perspectives
than they would if the internet didn't
exist and the answer to that is probably
on that yes there's some evidence to
that effect you can test the question
are people or certain numbers of people
using the Internet to sort themselves in
to echo chambers and the answer to that
one is also yes so what I'm thinking is
a question that has that level of
abstraction I think it's it's it's it's
a question that either makes people kind
of charged up upset if the answer is no
or that makes people relaxed and then
feel good the answer is yes and it's too
abstract a question I think to be the
correct one so if we ask a society
better off with automobiles my own view
is absolutely you can get places much
more easily than if we didn't have
automobiles but that answer to that
abstract question and even figure out
how to test that one's pretty
complicated obscures the fact that forty
thousand people died on the highways at
least did in 2016 so I think to focus on
concretely what's the internet doing is
probably the right way forward and what
I would prefer to do actually is to
focus on things that are problems
because if we have things that are
working well then there's really nothing
to do about them except bask in the the
pleasure that they're working well so
what can we make better what problems
are called up seems to me the the best
thing to do for trying to figure out how
to make our society better that's
exactly where we will pick up the
conversation with Cass Sunstein tomorrow
on the program we've been speaking about
the new book hashed
Republic divided democracy in the age of
social media and we'll continue our
conversation at that point
we're continuing our conversation today
with Cass Sunstein who's professor at
Harvard Law School also author of the
new book hashtag Republic divided
democracy in the age of social media
when we wrapped up in part one we were
starting to get in the direction of
thinking more concretely and
specifically about maybe solvable
problems ideally solvable problems and
in order to solve a problem we have to
sort of be specific about what it is
that we are trying to solve so as you
see it what are the most specific
concrete aspects of the problems created
by the echo chambers and these cyber
Cascades that you write about in the
book that we should be most focused on
and we know that if like-minded people
get together and talk mostly with each
other they become more confident more
unified and more extreme that's true
with a wide range of issues and I have
some data on it with respect to same-sex
relations and climate change and
affirmative action and if because of
social media
we have clumps of people let's say there
on the left who are stirring themselves
up into great clarity and confidence
about the correctness of their own view
and they're getting more extreme that is
bad both for them and for our
problem-solving capacities so it's bad
for them in the sense that their
ultimate judgments are a product of the
interactions which are pretty limited
with which they find themselves and it's
bad for society because how are they
going to deal with people who think
differently if they feel those different
views are crazy or hateful or you know
driven by a rigged system or something
and so the problem which goes by the
name of group polarization is the
intensification of views that come from
people who are sorting themselves into
clumps of the same kind birds of a
feather when they flock together in the
democratic processes that flock isn't
doing so great and so the problem is how
do we break down this is something the
framers of our Constitution were deeply
concerned about
situations in which people are thinking
as they do not because they're engaging
well with facts or with others but
because the the dynamic is is so limited
at a practical level what's the best way
to do that and to make people or I don't
I think make is actually the wrong word
but to suggest to individuals that there
may be other ideas altogether that
should be considerably there are those
like for example to borrow the term from
from Peter Boghossian that is sort of
Street epistemology working at the micro
level to make individuals sort of
examine why they believe what they
believe is what's necessary but that's
not really a scalable strategy at least
not in the way that Peter Boghossian
describes it so what sort of ideas do
you have about that well there's a
question of what should providers of
information whether they run podcasts or
websites or social media what should
they do and then there's a question what
kind of culture ought we to have and
what should individual judgments be
about what you're going to do with
respect to learning things in the next
month or year so for providers of
information the suggestion which is
actually time-honored is that an
architecture of serendipity let's call
it has fantastic advantages so if
there's a newspaper that you're reading
and let's say it's paper rather than
online you will see just by serendipity
ideas and topics that you would never
have chosen to see and just seeing those
we'll often at least in the course of
year often change your interest change
your perspective affect your values
sometimes even change your life so there
are common was people all over this
country certainly whose eyes have come
across something on a daily newspaper
and that's made them you know reorient
what they did in the next year and
sometimes in the next decade
so to prize an architecture of
serendipity for providers of information
is a great way of improving the
echo-chamber system
and it's nice to see that Facebook in
particular has been rethinking from the
public statements its values as
reflected in a very different conception
of the newsfeed which did not involve in
2016 serendipity but instead involved
something which I described as more much
more echo chamber II with respect to
each of us you know we can thank all of
us whether we want to highlight a
characteristic which makes human beings
different at least qualitatively at
least quantitatively and maybe
qualitatively too from other species
which is curiosity so each of us has
something in our head which is humble
and intrigued and puzzled and think you
know I'm not sure about this and I'm
intrigued by that thing which i think is
all wrong and I'm puzzled by an issue on
which at least with my friends I speak
with confidence and that leads those
characteristics leads naturally to
engagement with lots of different points
of view and interest in topics that
initially seem off-putting and one thing
we do find is for all the concern about
echo chamber creation that a lot of
people also use the internet to find
stuff that disturbs them in a way they
kind of like that because it expands
their horizons and that's sometimes fun
but whether or not it's fun it's
energizing are there legal changes that
you would like to see to make the
internet a friendlier I guess in this
sort of democratic way that we've been
talking about off hand I would not like
to see legal changes so when I hear
about legal changes I think about you
know something which goes under the
broad category of censorship or
regulation right and the Internet has a
kind of wildness which is part of its
charm and part of its Democratic
function so sure if people are using the
Internet to
you know bribe or threaten or or fix
prices that you can't use words to those
do those three things and you shouldn't
be allowed to do them on the internet
but I wouldn't want to change are very
robust free speech tradition to contract
this problem to think of private
solutions and culture is probably better
beyond just polarization in the book you
also talk about the way in which the
Internet as it is currently structured
can be a driver of extremism can you
talk a little bit about that yes so if
you get a group of people let's say
they're inclined to think America is
terrible
after they talk with each other they
tend to think America is not terrible
it's horrific if you've got a bunch of
people together who tend to think that
the Democratic Party is too
left-of-center after they talk with one
another they might well think lock her
up they're crooks and they're socialists
and that is a predictable consequence of
what happens when a group with an
initial set of opinions starts to listen
to the sources of those opinions that is
the source of those opinions will press
them in the direction of greater
extremism and we see that every day on
the Internet as people get you know very
clear in their head that the point of
view they have is correct but it's maybe
too moderate and they should push a bit
to the extreme in the worst forms of
this it does result in violence and
terrorist groups are often implicitly
well aware of the dynamic we're
discussing where they know if you can
get like-minded people together even
kind of vulnerable young people aren't
sure what they think they can they can
move very far and literally in dangerous
directions if we think about it as a
sort of math equation or on a time line
rather than it sounds like from what
you're saying
rather than a similarly similar
ideas leading to an outcome that is sort
of the average of those ideas it seems
that you get a bunch of people with
similar ideas talking and they end up
all moving to the position of the most
extreme members within that set is that
roughly what you're saying
yeah they move toward the position of
the more extreme member I actually did
some work on juries number of years ago
where I've read about it we initially we
traditionally tried to study this by not
having deliberating jury by having just
individuals and we assumed the median
would reflect what the jury would do and
then we did a follow up with
deliberating Tory's turned out we were
completely wrong I'd say it may be that
they move more toward the extreme member
but suppose you have a group of people
who are kind of a little right Oh Center
and there's no one in the group who's
extreme that group will predictably get
a lot right of center as they talk with
each other even if they don't have any
extreme person there because the
arguments they'll hear will skew right
and the arguments that skew left they're
not going to hear a lot of those because
the group skews right and then it's just
predictable that as they listen to one
another they're gonna move in a more
extreme direction so it's not as if the
most extreme member of the group is a
magnet it's that the distribution of
views if it skews one way or another
that's going to be reflected and what
people say and then the group's going to
go to the more extreme point absolutely
fascinating we've been speaking about
Cass Sunstein's new book hashtag
Republic divided democracy in the age of
social media he's a professor at Harvard
Law School so great talking to you about
this thank you I really enjoyed it I'm
grateful to you thanks